well guys hopefully you've had a chance
to see Thor the dark world are ready
because this review is gonna be spoiler
filled I got a lot of requests to do a
spoiler filled review of Thor the dark
world I try to do it with all the big
comic book films generally my fiance sam
joins me for these spoiler reviews but
she was not able to make it for this
video so let's get started on the
spoiler review of Thor the dark world
never talked about this movie opens with
a narration that explains everything
and I always kind of thought that was a
weak way to tell a story it's kind of
like this cop-out where you're like we
don't really know how to tell this
incredibly complicated story so we'll do
it through narration because that's the
best we can do and that's one of the
hardest things about the Thor comics is
that they're so out there and there's so
much information and so much backstory
and so much lore it's really hard to be
able to fit it into these more grounded
Marvel films that they're also making at
the same time but they do a really good
job with it I over all really enjoyed
the Thor the dark world I had a lot of
fun with the movie as I said in my
original review it was actually a film
that I enjoyed a little bit more than
the first one which is what I
essentially wanted we see Natalie
Portman and kat dennings and they're
observing things again and they're
looking for things and she misses Thor
and Kat things as annoying as hell but
she's there and what did he do there's
also an intern there now that also not
the whole human element of the Thor
movies I thought was always the weakest
but we immediately get to go off and see
Thor in battle with SIF and it's awesome
his first appearance in this movie is
awesome he just zaps into frame he takes
his hammer he slams it on the ground
whole bunch of people go down and stiff
is like I had this under control
and Thor's like then why is everything
on fire and then all these guys just
slam into him basically tackle him it
was a great shot I thought it was
exactly what I wanted out of Thor it
showed this great essence of fun where
Thor loves being in battle that's just
what he adores doing and I kind of
thought that element of fun was missing
from the first Thor because they showed
him in battle in the beginning and he
was having a lot of fun in the first
movie but then they said he was too
prideful and too haughty and he needed
to learn humility and so when he finally
did get to fight it was so serious like
I'm four and now I know my destiny that
essence of fun was sort of missing from
it in my opinion the same time going on
in the background is this dark elf
Malekith planning to harness this ether
the
that he can use to control the universe
and bring darkness upon everything is a
really weak villain in my opinion felt
like a Star Trek episode from the old
series and there were certain elements
of that whole villainy thing that I just
felt was not anywhere near as good as
Loki who is in this movie and is awesome
there's not enough of him though because
he's just freaking awesome and yes I
understand you can't have too much of a
good thing but I wanted more of Loki and
later on the movie there was this really
great scene that I really liked worth or
approaches Loki's chamber and he has
this illusion of himself looking all
proper after Thor's mother is killed and
thoughts like enough of these games Loki
and Loki reveals himself for what he
really is his room is trashed her stuff
all over the walls
he's sitting in the corner all tatter
he's not wearing his shoes he doesn't
care anymore his mom's dead he's so
upset he just wants revenge it's all I
could think about and I really like that
about that scene because one of the
coolest things about the Loki character
despite the fact that he's a great
villain he's funny he's entertaining he
has a human side to him as well where
you can actually kind of connect to him
and that's one of the reasons he's such
a good villain Thor and Loki decide to
team up because these Dark Elves have
taken over Asgard they killed a whole
bunch of people their ships crashed into
everything and they killed their mother
so they're gonna steal one of these
ships in this humongously epic plan that
involves treason and they're gonna zoom
off in this Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the Sith space battle esque
thing I enjoyed it though I had a good
time with it Natalie Portman was there
as well that's Padme that's interesting
but before they escape you get one of
the coolest cameos I've seen in any
Marvel movie and that was Chris Evans as
Captain America that was great the
theater erupted it was very well timed I
thought it was hilarious it really added
something to the movie it was also
really nice to see one of the Avengers
in another Marvel movie that happened
after the Avengers because that's one of
the things that a lot of people have
been like you know okay I get that all
this is going on the Avengers already
teamed up so why aren't they helping
this situation I get Thor that makes
sense because not everyone can just go
zap to Asgard at any time however an
Iron Man 3 I was like you know why
doesn't the whole just show up and help
out you know what I mean and so that
really felt right to actually have one
of the Avengers show up even if it was
fake I know it wasn't actually one of
the Avengers but it just it just felt
right now my favorite scene in the
entire movie
came next and that is where Thor and
Loki meet with Malekith and curse and
there's this giant battle that erupts
basically Loki stabs Thor you think oh
wow yeah he actually betrayed him he
falls down the mountain and he cuts off
Thor's hand as Thor is trying to get his
hammer and unfortunately I had heard on
the internet from various comic-con
leaks and stupid news articles that made
this their actual headline Thor loses
his arm in Thor - and I was like well
that's great nice to know that because
when that scene happened it didn't
really surprise me what did surprise me
though was when Thor revealed that it
was actually just a giant scheme and
Loki was in on it the whole time I was
like that's awesome
that is awesome as the coolest scene in
this whole movie because it also had a
great fight with curse which is
something that I thought was totally
missing from the main villain I didn't
find the main villain threatening Orin
in any way mentally or physically that
whole scene was great they zapped that
stuff out of Natalie Portman you think
she's gonna die and then the whole Loki
death happened you got to see Chris
Hemsworth giving a great performance as
a superhero with long hair and a red
cape and it worked like it worked I like
that about Thor the fact that they were
able to take this really out there story
that's so different and you know very
difficult to ground in some form of
reality and actually make you care but I
was also thinking that would really suck
if Loki was dead right now I'd be kind
of pissed it's like killing off the best
character and your whole thing you know
it's it's Loki and Tom Hiddleston just
rocks it and I was like no I can't
that's not a good idea and they didn't
really hold the whole mystery of him
being dead for very long they
immediately showed that other soldier
near like yeah that's Loki it didn't
really last that long I was surprised by
that too because it was like okay they
killed Loki if they really killed him
that sucks but they didn't really leave
the suspense for that long it's perhaps
because they knew fans would be really
pissed if Loki was dead so maybe they're
like well we better not hold that
suspense for too long there's the guy
that's Loki you'll figure that out
yourself later so a lot of things happen
stellan skarsgrd is running around
naked it's funny Darcy and the intern
are having romances again okay I guess
there's a giant epic end fight between
Thor and this guy he's zapping between
galaxies it's awesome I just wish the
villain was better than he was the
intern like picks up a floating car and
crushes some elves with it I was just
really dumb to me I that whole that
whole thing could have been gone from
this movie totally gone we get that
awesome
fanboy moment worth for and slow-motion
is like running with his hammer it's his
big epic things like I mean that's
basically what Thor is he hits things
with his hammer it's awesome all is
right in the world again Thor is
approaching his father Odin you saw
Anthony Hopkins early in the movie have
a moment where he sort of leans over and
he was like oh I don't feel good and
then he just sort of forgets about it
hinting that you know he's not in the
best of health he has a conversation
with Odin that was very Pro Loki and
wonder what's going on there Thor walks
away and it's revealed that Loki was
impersonating his father the entire time
now I don't know how many times they're
gonna use the whole Loki is
impersonating someone or Loki is not
actually there his illusion or what but
Thor always seems to fall for it because
Loki impersonating Odin means that he
finally has the throne to himself and he
is going to use that form to rule now
that's pretty cool because that could
take Thor 3 in a very interesting
direction I mean to have the war
figuring out things with his father and
as that Loki figuring out where Anthony
Hopkins is the deception that Loki could
possibly use in that position that is
just ripe with great story elements I
don't think they'll do that in Avengers
2 that's way too much heavy stuff to
just talk about in Avengers 2 I it might
be hinted at but I feel like with these
movies and so many characters that it
just has to be like as condensed a story
as possible so I feel like that probably
will be saved for Thor 3 and we have two
end credits scene let's just talk about
the least interesting one first that's
at the very end
Thor comes back to earth II kisses
Natalie Portman it's like a romance
movie all of a sudden for some reason
and then one of the space creatures is
jumping around and that was pretty funny
that was entertaining I enjoyed seeing
that because it was sort of like a
Breaking Bad finale moment we were like
hey what happened to Huell he's just in
the safe house still isn't he well that
sucks
cuz the end of the Thor you're like hey
what happened that giant creature I
guess he's just running around on earth
no I don't know if that means that Thor
is gonna stay on earth or he's just
gonna come back every once in a while
for a booty call
either way please don't stay on earth
Asgard is much more interesting than
earth thank you but the one before that
is definitely the more interesting one
and that is the one that hypes guardians
of the galaxy now you got Benicio del
Toro in there as the collector and he's
like oh we do I'll be honest with you I
was like what that's kind of weird I
have a
that guardians of the galaxy is a type
of movie that benefits from being there
from scene one so you can kind of get
into that oddness you know not just be
like here's this world it's weird you
know what I mean because hopefully from
seeing one of guardians of the galaxy
you can actually be like yes this is
what the movie is gonna be like who
takes this thing from Lady stiffin
Volstagg and you're wondering what that
is it is the ether it's one of the
Infinity stones that will eventually
assemble to create the Infinity Gauntlet
which is this giant form of power this
guy collects everything and it has
something to do with gardens of the
galaxy which we will find out very soon
could lead to big epic things every
single Marvel ending is always something
cool and interesting that everyone is
always wanting to see every time I go to
a Marvel movie I'm like why are people
getting up why are you it's not over
there's gonna be a thing it's every time
there's gonna be something oh and I
really enjoyed Thor the dark world as
you know there were things about that
surprised me there were weak story
elements to it as well the whole human
thing I just feel like can be trashed
but I understand Thor has to be
connected with earth in some way so that
he can have something to do in the
Avengers so what do you guys think of
the movie now that you've seen it
hopefully you have seen it before you
watch this video because I just told you
everything it happens unless you don't
give a crap and that's cool too I guess
guys thanks as always very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my nest
[Music]